[Musique]
jeudi 26 février 2015 et les 14 59 je
suis assise dans le taxi
mon ami samir a est à ma gauche je suis
nerveuse j'ai des boutons doucement mon
manteau dehors les homos fixe déjà je
sens de la tension monte il faut que je
le fasse je vous aller au bout je sors
il est 15 heures je vous la porte du
suis sur mes deux pieds de boue je suis
qu'à nous mais je me sens fort mais
poids se sert et j'avance je marche je
regarde droit devant moi
de plus en plus d'hommes arrivent
j'ai eu le centre de tous les regards
tous marchent avec moi certainement
regarde telmo fixe mots qu'ils tombent
ils moqueries dessous rôle j étrangères
charles landry mais tapantes des menaces
il est complètement folle folle chaissac
sale [ __ ] à l'intérieur je hurle venez
venez chien bien une vache est bien
rodée ni charles bety moins montrer
votre vrai visage
montrez votre vraie nature ar cela
au milieu de cette foule je me suis
revue petit quand je pleurais en cash et
john wall et où quand ma mère m'a bateau
avec un fil électrique
c'est vrai qu'au petit on vous disait
tout le temps que j'étais folle folle
d'avoir dessiné les femmes nous après
une visite aura m'en voulais d'avoir
dansé les fesses et le poitrine
rembourré pour être comme ces femmes que
j'avais vu dans les marais âge vous
limitez les adultes leur façon de parler
du bouger faute de partir dans mes
pensées comme absente volet des formes
et mon visage
amusé par les grimaces folle d'exagérer
légiste de ma prière
juste pour rire faux d'essayer de
ressentir ce que c'est d'être un objet
en prenant la forme d'une chaise d'amour
d'une table mais ces trains mais chaque
foulée mon vallée du coup ma mère m'ont
répété qu'il faudrait deux mois une
fille bien et j'en prends je ne rentrais
pas dans le moule l'écoutent ma mère
c'était pour me protéger des hommes leur
coût aurait fait beaucoup plus mal
ma mère ma mère
c'était elle qui m'a appris à me
soumettre à endurer à me sacrifier
elle m'a appris le patriarcat elle dit à
moi et mes cinq sort il n'y a rien pour
nous dans le vie et le raconter des
histoires de femmes pour leur rappeler
de résister nous avons le droit
d'exister il fallait exister sous le
pression des hommes mais existait quand
même ma mère était parfaite
elle tenait en une maison impeccable
avec des enfants sages il prépare l
europe 1 et moi j'ai la dernière car il
reste quelque chose et le fou ma
première figures féministes
quand j'avais 5 ans je vivais avec ma
famille en iran
nous étions réfugiés pour fuir la guerre
en afghanistan
là bas s'il vous attraper ils tuaient
les hommes mais il violer et tuer les
femmes
j'ai trouvé ça injuste inégalités entre
les hommes et les femmes
nous pourrions mourir de voir ma mère
insisté sur l'importance de rester
vierge et il fallait toujours se méfier
des hommes ça n'a rien empêché je
n'avais que 5 ans quand les
attouchements et violon commencé à 10
ans nous avons dû fuir les rangs pour
trouver refuge au pakistan
mon père est mort peu de temps après il
fallait travailler nous étaient enfermés
à la maison toute la journée
judicieux des tapis toujours en cours
d'étape et je travaille tellement que
j'ai oublié de manger quelques fois bien
évidemment nous participons aussi aux
tâches ménagères et le soir l'aube audio
après 12 heures comme ça nous sommes
enfin retourner à l'école le matin
et bien sûr toujours les tapis les
tâches ménagères les boîtes de broderie
moi je n'avais qu'un seul bouton et est
allé à kaboul
étudier être artiste
j'économise et chaque pièce pour vivre
mon rêve mais mon rêve avait un ennemi
le mariage forcé mes soeurs adolescentes
parts et les unes après les autres et se
retrouver marie à des inconnus pour moi
aussi tout était arrangé à 14 ans on
m'avait déjà trouvé un marais c'est une
grande fierté car j'ai réussi à
convaincre ma mère de ne pas me marier
je voulais être un artiste
et pour ça il fallait que je sois libre
je me voyais déjà l'ire de tout faire
par moi-même vire seul à kaboul étudiez
créé découvrir le monde
c'était mon rêve ça allait être le
paradis pour la première fois on atteint
j'arrive à cabris chez avec mon frère à
la sortie de la saisine du bus nous nous
retrouvons devant le rhône poids du côté
sanguin c'est ici que ma vie allait
complètement changer quelques années
plus tard j'étais admise au bord du
chaos oui j'allais en fait être
indépendante mais j'ai vite déchanté la
vie de femme hors de mariage n'était pas
le paradis que j'avais imaginé le danger
était présente au quotidien et
l'harcèlement constante
jeudi 26 février 2015 15h01 gît sur le
rhône poids de côté singles je suis au
centre d'un cyclone dont ils sont fous
furieux je marche mon armure mot
protéger
cela fait un mois que je la classerais
une heure chaque jour
j'ai vendu chaque pièce olmeta je lui
fais une poitrine et des fesses
généreuses
je marche mon armure sur le dos ça le
rendait fou juste marcher sans dire un
mot juste ça une performance artistique
un marcheur duré une minute je recevais
des projectiles des insultes la pression
devenait trop fort je suis remonté dans
le taxi et nous avons filé caché schelin
ordinaire ou journaliste australien j'ai
vu ma photo partout sur le v à la télé
les journaux
la colère monte chaque jour je ne
pouvais plus sortir grâce à salim
arrache mine depuis pakistan mais aussi
grâce à franz marc année du l'unesco à
paris j'ai pu quitter le pays j'ai dû
fuir
mais pourquoi fuir est ce que je suis si
dangereuse qu'un terroriste pour le pays
j'ai vécu pratiquement toute ma vie
réfugiés avec ma famille je m'étais
pourtant battu pour vivre à kaboul en
afghanistan
aujourd'hui je vis à paris j'ai une
bonne vie normalement je devrais me
calmer mais ce que j'ai vécu
le pression parce que je suis une femme
est toujours là je parlais de cette
culture de violence actuelle pour ne pas
déranger le monde nous nous taisons nous
devons nous les alliés des agresseurs de
cette culture nous les protégeons en
afghanistan le violeur se vante même de
l'osé de leurs exploits qui protège la
p'tite vite fille de cinq ans qui toute
sa vie va se taire maintenant que je vis
ici je comprends que la violence
actuelle n'est pas con afghanistan ici
en occident le patriarcat existe aussi
pas extrêmes comme afghanistan mais mais
existent sous le forme plus sophistiqués
avec mes performances j'ai envie de
casser les mourres que j'ai construit
pour me protéger
j'ai besoin d'être vulnérable sans
protection demanderait la laideur et la
violence de mes émotions
j'explore la souffrance je leur visite
end pointe où j'ai construit ma propre
pays bing ou g du mondial spectateurs de
nous pousser du pied de traitement corps
comme un objet than the mansion une
collaboration avec une artiste allemande
et jf sur l'eau intersectionnelle
féminisme price check in paris j'ai
marché 15 jours dans paraît tout les
objets que je ramenais de kaboul sur la
tête toute ma vie sur ma tête
harmonie
qui représente la façon dont j'ai vécu
la religion non seulement les poids de
masclat sur mon dos jusqu'à l'épuisement
et dj performance je porte un costume
rempli de sel l'eau coule sur ma tête
le seul fonds se le représente la mer
les merlas pour servir pour se sacrifier
cela paie je me donnait des claques je
voulais rendre la violence normal à
force d'être exposé printemps on laisse
que mon chien je supplie l'art - dieu
c'est la seule manière pour moi de ne de
ne pas oublier j'utilise la puissance de
l'image parler n'est pas suffisant je
veux être sûr d'être vous d'être entendu
nous les femmes afghanes ne sont pas
visibles nous n'avons pas d'identité
dans ces sociétés nous sommes ignorés
nous ne comptons pas aujourd'hui ma
responsable responsabilité artistique
est bien plus large qu enfin parler au
cou aux femmes afghanes et les de
m'adresser au monde entier je participe
souvent des événements artistiques avec
du public et je suis étonné de la
réaction du jeune homo féminisme on
dirait quoi ce mot fait peur
on y re je fais peur parce que jean
présente comme un artiste féministe je
reçois des préjugés forte ici pour moi
c'est c'est juste une recherche
d'égalité et de défense des droits de
l'homme avec un grand h bien sûr on me
dit de ne pas utiliser le mot féministe
mais plutôt activistes légende ma
demande quelle image légitimité à parler
de ça - femmes afghanes on nous dit ce
mot n'existe même pas dans nos langues
en effet
j'ai découvert le moins très tard mais
pourtant j'ai eu toujours une petite
féministes ou de moi je voyais les
inégalités et je me rebelle est même si
à l'adolescence j'ai failli tuer ma
petite féministe car je voulais aussi
être une bonne fille est appliqué la
religion à la lettre même si je voulais
devenir la vie comme la ficome voilà
c'est donc rêvé ma mère mais mais mon
rêve et l'art était beaucoup plus fort
certains disent qu ils cherchent
l'argent l'attention de le pouvoir mais
pourtant j'ai perdu beaucoup la famille
mes amis mon pays mon entourage ou si
elle se faire il souffre encore des
conséquences de monde parfois mance
ma seule battait a toujours été d'être
artiste est de pouvoir exprimer mon
identité mon histoire ma sexualité avec
lundi dans les discussions avec les
femmes afghanes français ou d'ailleurs
nous partageons nos histoires on se dit
les souffrances les vieux le cash et les
injustices
alors
on a une grande compréhension entre nous
pourquoi on peut pas en parler
ouvertement parlé de ça aussi d'éclairer
féministes nous devons nous aussi tuân
désirable j'aimerais défendre le mot
féminisme la vie d'une féministe
commence par elle-même notre féminisme
or si on ne prend pas soin c'est notre
responsabilité nous de vous trouver
notre identité et ne plus avoir honte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]